isn't it
democratic leaders i ask unanimous
consent the quorum be dispensed with
without objection thank you madam
president now this week
the senate will continue confirming
president biden's highly qualified and
history-making cabinet nominees
in a few hours we'll hold a vote on
janet yellen to serve as the next
secretary of the treasury
janet yellen of course is no stranger to
this chamber
she's been confirmed by the senate no
fewer than four times
and was reported favorably to the floor
by a unanimous vote
of the finance committee on friday the
bipartisan support from ms yellen's
multiple nominations
reflects her breathtaking range of
experience
and just how well-suited she is to
manage the economic challenges of our
time
ms yellen i'm proud to report is a
native of working class brooklyn
the daughter of a school teacher and a
physician raised during the great
depression
she went to fort hamilton high school
one of james madison high school's
rivals
a graduate of brown and yale miss yellen
has taught economics
as at some of the world's most
prestigious universities
of course janet yellen is best known for
her chair
for her tenure as chair of the federal
reserve
overseeing a period of falling
unemployment and steady economic
recovery from the global financial
crisis
few people possess the experience and
expertise
that miss yellen would bring to the
treasury particularly during this moment
of economic crisis
at the treasury department there are
long hallways on the third floor
where the portraits of all 77 treasury
secretaries hang
all of the men all the way back to
alexander hamilton the first secretary
i am thrilled today to vote to confirm
the first woman
to ever hold the position of treasury
secretary
and someday add her portrait to that
hallway
on that note i would add it was a great
pleasure to read the biden
administration's announcement today that
the treasury department intends to speed
up the plans
to add the portrait of harriet tubman to
the twenty dollar bill
this is an issue i have long championed
and something that should have been done
a long time ago
i feel particularly strong about it
since harriet tubman was an
auburn new york resident and our office
worked for years to successfully make
her home in upstate new york
a national historic monument
and i'm glad the biden administration is
reversing the trump administration's
foot dragging
this is the kind of things they did no
excuse no reason
just didn't do it but now the biden
administration is reversing the trump
administration's foot dragging and will
press
forward with plans to circulate new
currency
celebrating harriet tubman's life and
legacy
now after miss yellen's confirmation
tonight the senate will continue to
process nominations to president biden's
cabinet
the secretaries of state homeland
security and transportation
with cooperation the senate could
complete both confirmations this week
again those are the secretaries of state
homeland security and transportation
in addition to treasury this evening i'd
remind my colleagues that president
trump
had his secretary of homeland security
installed on inauguration day
we cannot allow our national security
our domestic security to be compromised
in any way
by the prolonged delay of mr mayorkas
nomination
on impeachment as i announced on friday
the republican leader and i have come to
an initial agreement about the timing of
the impeachment trial of donald trump
this evening managers appointed by the
house of representatives
will deliver to the senate the article
of impeachment and will read the article
here
in the well of this chamber tomorrow
senators will be sworn in as judges and
jurors in the impending trial
and the senate will issue its summons
to former president trump after that
both the house managers and the former
president's council will have a period
of time to draft their legal briefs
just as they did in previous trials once
the briefs are drafted
presentations by the parties will
commence the week of february
8. i want to thank the republican leader
for working with us to reach this
agreement
which we believe is fair to both sides
and
will enable the senate to conduct a
timely and fair trial
on the article of impeachment the
schedule will also allow us to continue
the important work of the people
including confirming more members of
president biden's cabinet
but i want to be very clear about that
last point the senate
will conduct a timely and fair
trial i want to be very clear about that
because some of my republican colleagues
have latched on to a fringe legal theory
that the senate does not have the
constitutional power to hold a trial
because donald trump
is no longer in office this argument has
been roundly debunked by constitutional
scholars from the left right and center
it defies precedent historic practice
and basic common sense it makes no sense
whatsoever that a president or any
official
could commit a heinous crime against our
country and then defeat congress's
impeachment powers by simply resigning
so as to avoid accountability and a vote
to disqualify them
from future office this isn't merely a
hypothetical situation madam president
in 1876 president grant secretary of war
william belnap
implicated in a corruption scheme
literally race through the white house
to tender his resignation mere minutes
before the house was set to vote on his
impeachment
then as a matter of historical record he
burst into tears
not only did the house move forward with
five impeachment articles against him
but a trial was then convened in the
senate
of course the question came up as to
whether the senate could try officials
former could try former officials and
guess what
the senate voted as a chamber that mr
belnap could be tried
quote for acts done as secretary of war
notwithstanding his resignation of said
office
those are words the senate voted in 1876
now mr belnap was ultimately acquitted
but the record's clear
the senate decided it had the power to
try former officials
and the reasons are obvious a president
or any official could for example wait
until their final two weeks in office to
portray their country knowing they could
escape accountability
or merely resign moments before the
senate decides to convict and disqualify
them from future office
the theory that the senate can't try
former officials
would amount to a constitutional get out
of jail free card for
any president who commits an impeachable
offense
now it's certainly appropriate for the
senate to take the resignation of an
official into account
after all the house decided not to
impeach richard nixon because in that
sense
nixon took some responsibilities for his
actions
but to state the obvious president trump
did not resign
he has not demonstrated remorse he has
not even acknowledged his role
in the events of january 6th and he has
never disavowed the lies that were fed
to the american people
by him about who actually won the
election
just to put a final nail into the coffin
of this ridiculous theory
i'd remind my colleagues if a president
is convicted on an article of
impeachment the senate holds a separate
vote
on whether to bar them from future
office once a president is convicted of
an impeachment charge they're removed
from office in other words they become a
former official
if we are to believe that the senate
can't hold former officials to account
then the senate could never proceed to
that second vote of disqualification
which is provided for in the
constitution
even for a sitting president in saying
this
i'm expressing the view of legal
scholars across the political spectrum
stephen vladick a prominent
constitutional expert at the university
of texas
wrote in the new york times that donald
trump is quote the poster child
for why the conviction of an
ex-president does not just
constitutionally permissible
but necessary more than 150 legal
scholars signed a letter last week
forcefully stating that an impeachment
trial of a former president
is constitutional among the signatories
one of the co-founders
of the federalist society as well as one
of president reagan's solicitor generals
among other prominent conservatives
it is so obviously wrong to suggest that
impeaching a president
is unconstitutional that impeaching a
former president is unconstitutional
so why are some suggesting it well there
seems to be a desire on the political
right to avoid passing judgment one way
or the other
on former president trump and his role
in fomenting the despicable attack on
the capital january 6.
there seems to be some hope that
republicans could oppose the former
president's impeachment prop
impeachment on process grounds rather
than grappling with his actual
awful conduct let me very be very clear
this is not going to fly the trial is
going to happen
it is certainly and clearly
constitutional
and if the former president is convicted
there will be a vote to disqualify him
from future office
there is only one question at stake only
one question
that senators of both parties will have
to answer before god and their own
conscience is
former president trump guilty of
inciting
an insurrection against the united
states
i yield the floor
note the absence of a quan the clerk
will call the world
ms baldwin
you
kind of present the republican leader is
recognized
as content to further proceed on the
quorum call be dispensed with
without objection madam president our
nation has spent nearly a year
locking this terrible battle with covet
19.
this virus that spread from china around
the world has taken more than
four hundred thousand american lives
it's effectively cost many children an
entire
school year it made us slam the brakes
on one of the best job markets in modern
history
and through millions of families into
financial chaos
but thanks to a lot of hard work in 2020
the dawn of 2021 has brought
a turning point the genius of science
and the support of operation warp speed
produced vaccines
in record time and in december after
months of delay democrats finally let
congress move ahead with another major
rescue package
the light at the end of the tunnel is
getting closer
and both republicans and democrats want
to continue working together
to accelerate victory curiously the
president's candidate to run the
department of health and human services
is the famously partisan attorney
general of california
his recent experience in health policy
seems largely limited to promoting
abortion on demand
and suing groups like the little sisters
of the poor
who dare to live out their religious
convictions
in an interview just yesterday mr
becerra compared the current state of
vaccinations inherited by the biden
administration
to an airplane in a nosedive a disaster
he contrasted the status quo with the
new administration's
stated goal of one million vaccinations
per day
which he called quote ambitious
there's a problem here even the press
has repeatedly pointed it out
it's that our nation is already meeting
that very pace
already meeting the very pace
that's not a big new goal it's exactly
what they inherited from the trump
administration
and operation warp speed
inauguration day thursday
and friday each topped one million
vaccinations as of today we're averaging
1.16 million
shots per day over the last week
they're claiming the exact same number
can either be a total catastrophe or a
smashing success
i guess depends on whether democrats are
in power
so much for science without politics
here's how the washington post put it
the accelerating speed of the vaccine
program
undercuts assertions by some biden
advisors
that they were left no plan by the trump
administration and suggests that they
need only to keep their
feet on the pedal to clear the bar they
set for themselves
end quote yesterday mr becerra was asked
about increasing vaccinations in the
month ahead
here's what he said i first have to be
sworn in
to give you a timeline perhaps that's
like the time the speaker of the house
famously said she has to pass a bill
before the public could learn what was
in it
the new administration campaigned
heavily on having a new master plan
to fight the pandemic well now they're
in office
president biden has said quote there's
nothing we can do to change the
trajectory of the pandemic in the next
several months
and his administration is apparently
content to maintain
the same vaccine pace they actually
inherited
let's talk about congress role in
pandemic relief our democratic
colleagues spent last summer and fall
using the legislative filibuster to
delay the next rescue package
until after the election now that would
be the same tool that some senate
democrats now suddenly say they oppose
as if they hadn't leaned on it liberally
over the last six years but finally last
month
they let us act we passed another
package totaling nearly
900 billion dollars in urgent relief
we provided more than 80 billion dollars
to help k-12 schools
280 billion dollars for the paycheck
protection program
billions more for federal unemployment
insurance supplements
nutrition and rental assistance and
direct cash aid and massive new
investments
in purchasing and distributing vaccines
some of that money has already gone out
the door other portions are still
unspent
a massive historic almost trillion
dollar package that was passed into law
just five weeks ago since last march
washington dc has spent an historic
amount of money standing up one of the
most enormous policy responses
by any government to any emergency that
the world has ever seen
nobody thinks the support has been
perfect far from it
but it has been historic and strong
for example a non-partisan study in
november showed that because of the
historic emergency legislation passed
through congress
american personal income was actually
listened to this
higher in september than it had been
before the pandemic last month larry
summers president clinton's treasury
secretary and president obama's nec
director confirmed that relative to our
underlying economy our multiple rescue
packages have brought american house
goal income
all the way back to a level that equals
or even exceeded
what he'd expect if we weren't in a
crisis
so to be clear madam president nobody
thinks our bipartisan work
fighting this pandemic is completely
finished nobody's arguing that and we
all understand that overall national
statistics do not explain away the
terrible struggles facing
many families but experts and economists
from the left to the right agree any
further action should be
smart and targeted not just an
imprecise deluge of borrowed money
that would direct huge sums toward those
who don't need it
that's why the new administration's
first draft of their sprawling proposal
misses the mark and press reports make
clear
this is not just a republican view
multiple democratic senators agree that
it's not
the right path forward so
as the 900 billion dollar package from
five weeks ago continues to come online
and as remaining needs continue to come
into focus
republicans will be ready and eager to
continue bipartisan discussions about
smart
steps forward for the american people
bipartisan action helped our nation
endure the last year
bipartisan action helped us turn the
corner
and it will be smart bipartisan actions
that help us
finish the fight
now on a related matter this afternoon
the senate will confirm dr janet yellen
the former chair of the federal reserve
to serve as president biden's secretary
of the treasury
her speedy confirmation will contrast
sharply with the way the senate
democratic minority handled many of the
last president's key cabinet nominations
four years ago
secretary mnuchin had to sit through a
stunt where senate democrats literally
boycotted his committee hearing
he was not confirmed until mid-february
dr yellen came out of committee on a
unanimous vote
and will be getting to work five days
after the inauguration
that's even faster than secretary
geithner's nomination
in 2009 in the teeth of the financial
crisis
this certainly isn't because dr yellen
or president biden's economic policy
views have unanimous support here in the
senate
i expect we'll have no shortage of
spirited policy discussions with dr
yellen in the months ahead
especially if some democrats keep trying
to use this historic emergency as a
pretext
a pretext to push through permanent
far-left policy changes
the 50 senators on our side have great
confidence in our pro-job pro-worker
vision that helped build the greatest
job market in living memory
but the simple fact is that when the
american people elect a president
and when the president selects qualified
and mainstream people for key posts
the whole nation deserves for them to be
able to assemble
their team i'll be voting to confirm dr
yellen today
i look forward to working together on
pro-growth policies that will help
rebuild a thriving economy for american
workers
that was in place just one year ago
under the previous order the leadership
time is reserved
morning business is closed under the
previous order the senate will proceed
to executive session to consider the
following nomination
which the clerk will report
nomination department of the treasury
janet louise yellen of california to be
secretary
under the previous order the time until
5 30 will be equally divided between
the two leaders or their designees
republican leader
the clerk will call the world miss
baldwin
you
you
you
foreign
madam president senator from ohio thank
man president i ask
uh you know sent to dispense with quorum
without objection
thank you madam president good to see
the senator from hawaii uh
as a presiding officer i i rise today to
honor
workers in this building something that
senator rono does
every day of her job life in this job to
ra honor workers in this building who
are too often overlooked
but whose work is essential to the
functioning of our government
our capital custodial staff in the days
after the
january sixth insurrection when domestic
terrorists stormed this building
we outrightly honored capitol police
officer eugene goodman
and many other capitol police officers
who put their lines
lives on the line to protect all of us
to protect our democratic process to
essentially to protect our democracy
last week i joined a bipartisan group of
colleagues in introducing legislation
to ward officer goodman the
congressional gold medal
he and others may well have saved our
lives and protected our democracy
they did it without the support they
needed from their leadership they did it
without the support
from the trump white house on down but
those officers aren't the only ones who
deserve our honor and our gratitude
they are not the only ones who put their
lives on their lines serving our country
on january 6th or over the past year
during this pandemic
every day capital custodial staff do
their jobs
with skill and dedication and dignity
they show up for work during this
pandemic even when
many in this building didn't take it
seriously and put those workers health
risk
health at risk by not wearing masks
capital custodial workers were here
january 6 doing their jobs
when white supremacists stormed this
building barging into this chamber
acting as this
as though no one could ever possibly
hold them accountable
because the president was on their side
they thought they were
invulnerable and when their rampage was
over
it was largely the black and brown
custodians who were left to restore
dignity and respect to the capital
their work allowed us to continue hours
that night certifying the electoral
votes
securing our democracy the election in
our democracy
many americans were so moved to see
those workers still doing their job
that's what service looks like that's
what love of country looks like that's
what the dignity of work
is all about unfortunately tells you a
whole lot about the problems that have
been allowed to fester
for too long in this country white
supremacists make a mess
black workers clean it up we have a lot
of work to do to fix that to ensure that
hard work
pays off for all workers in this country
we simply don't value
and respect all work the way we should i
think of the words of dr
king who as you know died fighting for
workers because those
sanitation workers in memphis he said
if a man is called to be a street
sweeper he should sweep streets even as
michelangelo painted
or beethoven composed music or
shakespeare wrote
poetry he should sweep streets so well
that all the hosts of heaven and earth
will pause to say
here lived a great sweet street sweeper
who did his job well
dr king said no work is insignificant
all labor that uplifts humanity
has dignity and importance no work is
insignificant
all labor has dignity we ought to treat
it that way
starting with honoring these workers in
the days after january
6 pictures of capital workers cleaning
up after these terrorists were reported
on the news
captured by dedicated journalists who
also risked their lives
to do their jobs that day these photos
struck a chord with so many people
americans began writing thank you
letters sending them to the architect of
the capitol to pass on
to custodial staff to police officers
and to others
many of these workers are represented by
asthma local 626
which gives workers a voice on the job
is also working
on ways to honor its members members of
congress should do the same
in the coming weeks i'll be introducing
a senate resolution
to recognize the capital custodial staff
for their bravery and their service to
our country on january 6th
i hope my colleagues will join me all of
them not as
republicans or democrats but as as
members of this body as americans all
this capital is the people's house the
insurrectionist
ransacked it the capital custodians
picked up the pieces
they deserve our eternal gratitude to
all the custodial
capital custodians who come to work in
this building each day
to ensure our democracy functions thank
you thank you
thank you mr president i ask
that the following being sorted as
put a different place in the record
without objection
thank you ma'am president a few days
after our first woman vice president was
sworn in we're about to confirm
the first woman to step into one of the
leading roles in our economy
janet yellen made history when she
served as chair of the federal reserve
she's about to make history again as
secretary of the treasury
she'll be the first person to ever have
held all three of the top positions in
our economy
chair of the council of economic
advisers secretary
chair of the federal reserve secretary
of the treasury
and now more than ever we need her
leadership provision or appreciation for
what makes this country work
as fed chair and as a labor economist
janet yellen made it clear she
understands what drives
our economy it's not the stock market
it's not wall street's people it's
workers
janet yellen knows our economy is built
by americans who know
the dignity of a hard day's work whether
you punch a clock or swipe a badge
or work for tips or care for children or
take care for care
care for your parents i remember in 2015
jerry yellen came to cleveland
and toured the alcoa plant not far from
my house
she showed the kind of leadership we
need the kind of leaders
president biden is putting into the top
jobs managing our economy people who
will get out of washington who will
visit every sort of
community in the heart of the country
people who act in what they learn from
workers in chillicothe in springfield
in youngstown and moline illinois where
the next presiding officer is coming
from
there's a lot more to our economy than a
quarterly earnings report
janet yellen understands that she will
step into this job
at a time when the contrast between the
financial help of corporations and
workers
couldn't be starker or in the midst of a
public health crisis
and an economic crisis you wouldn't know
it if you only looked at the stock
market
or corporate profits but under president
biden under janet yellen
and under new leadership in the senate
we're done measuring we're just done
measuring the economy that way
we're going to think about the economy
the way workers and their families do in
terms of paychecks
whether they can make rent or pay the
mortgage this month or afford child care
or pay for their prescription drugs
by those measures madam president people
are hurting
we hear a lot about what some people
call called the case-shaped recovery
that's one way of saying
that the rich are getting richer while
the middle-class and low-income families
continue to struggle
it was a problem before this virus madam
president as you know the pandemics only
made it worse
it's layered on top of systemic racism
and inequality
that have been allowed to fester for too
long we have a tax code that favors the
wealthy
that gives corporations a tax break when
they move
manufacturing out of east st louis or
out of east cleveland
overseas americans hard-earned savings
are at risk from the financial
instability of climate change china is
aggressive
confident and continues to threaten
american jobs the internal revenue
service wastes time and taxpayer money
auditing working families often black
and brown families
instead of going after wealthy tax
cheats
wall street rewards corporations lay off
employees and cut their pay and treat
their workers as expendable
risky behavior in wall street like it
did in the last crisis
can devastate communities in ohio and
around the country
i have confidence that janet yellen
understands these vast challenges
that she'll get to work immediately to
take them on to create a better
more prosperous more stable economy
centered on the dignity of work
she knows we can build new cleaner
infrastructure that puts people to work
at good paying union jobs we can invest
you know in the country including
the small towns and industrial cities
and of southeast ohio and southern
illinois
and the black and brown communities in
our cities that too
often get left behind we can make it
easier for people to afford housing
in transportation and child care we can
treat a tax code
that rewards work instead of wealth
starting with the dramatic expansion
of the child tax credit and the earned
income tax credit
we can give people more power over their
lives
in their own money with with options
like monthly distribution of the child
tax credit
and no fee bank accounts that's the
vision janet yellen and joe biden and
senate democrats
are committed to one where the middle
class is growing and everyone has the
opportunity to join it
janet yellen has the experience the
talent and the commitment
to service to deliver results she's the
right person
for these tumultuous times she's she
will rise to meet this moment
to help our country build back better i
ask my colleagues
to support janet yellen for secretary of
the treasury
i note the absence of a quorum
the clerk will call the roll mr
alexander
miss baldwin
foreign
is senator from texas and a president
i'd ask unanimous consent that the
quorum call be dispensed with
without objection madam president last
week
the country and the world watched as our
nation carried out one of its most
sacred traditions the peaceful transfer
of power
which is the hallmark of american
democracy it has defined our country
since its earliest
days between the pandemic and
heightened security concerns this
inauguration looked far
different than those of former
presidents but the will of the people
was carried out
just as it has been following every
presidential election
throughout our nation's history
president biden and his inaugural
address stressed the importance of
unifying our country
i agree and i hope the president and our
democratic colleagues
in congress lead by example
our first order of business has been to
fill critical positions throughout the
federal government
and the senate's already confirmed both
the director of national intelligence
and the secretary of defense
both of whom i supported this afternoon
we'll vote on the confirmation of janet
yellen to be treasury secretary
who i intend to vote for as well and
there's a slate of other important
positions we need to be
that need to be filled in the coming
days and weeks
i should note that voting to confirm a
nominee
under the words of the constitution
providing advice and consent
is not a rubber stamp of the
administration's policies i know there
will be important issues that we will
disagree on
but if elections mean anything they mean
that the prevailing party should not be
kneecapped
as unfortunately our democratic
colleagues did in the previous
administration when they try to install
a new cabinet
and agency heads but rather i believe
the tradition has been to accommodate
one another when we can so the
administration can carry on
and carry out their duties this morning
i had a very good conversation with
judge merrick garland
who president biden is nominated for
attorney general
judge garland's extensive legal
experience makes him well suited
to lead the department of justice and i
appreciated his commitment to keep
politics
out of the justice department that is my
number one
criterion for who should be the next
head of the department of justice as
attorney general
and i think both sides should support
a de-politicized justice department
and that's what i hope judge garland
once confirmed will deliver
i look forward to talking to him more
during the confirmation process
but unless i hear something new i expect
to support his nomination before the
full
senate it's in the best interest of the
country to have qualified senate
confirmed
individuals leading our federal
departments and agencies
as we look beyond the confirmation
process there are many opportunities for
republicans and democrats
to work together in those places where
we agree
and i know additional coronavirus relief
as it's needed is high on president
biden's list
approximately one million americans are
being vaccinated every day
and while the light at the end of the
tunnel is getting bigger and brighter
we're still not in the clear congress
has provided trillions of dollars in
relief to strengthen our
fight on both the health care and
economic fronts but we need to remain
vigilant in the final critical phase
of this battle i don't support president
biden's
pandemic relief proposal in its current
form
but i do believe it's a starting point
for bipartisan negotiations
i'll gladly support a reasonable
targeted bill as we determine precisely
as we can where the needs truly are
we all agree we need to bolster vaccine
manufacturing and
distribution that some americans need
additional financial support
and that main street businesses in their
workforce
are still struggling to survive this
economic
recession i hope the administration will
be willing to work with congress to
reach an agreement that receives broad
bipartisan support as each of the
previous bills
that we have passed has
during my time in the senate i've worked
with folks across the aisle on our
shared priorities
and i have no plans of changing that
practice now
but make no mistake i'll push back
forcefully
respectfully when the president and i
disagree one of the things i have
learned though is that there is a
difference between
what some elected officials say and what
they actually
do and rather than listen to what they
say i
really prefer to watch what they do and
see if those are consistent
only hours after being sworn in and
speaking of unifying the country
president biden unilaterally cancelled
the permit for the keystone xl pipeline
and that same day the administration
halted
all new energy leasing and permitting on
public lands and waters
well with these unfortunate actions
president biden is killing
thousands of well-paying u.s jobs
and kicking the u.s energy industry
while it's still
struggling with the pandemic
i had hoped i still hope to work with
president biden on an
all of the above energy strategy
that prioritizes our fossil fuels
we have 280 million cars on the road the
people are going to still need gasoline
for the foreseeable future
but also renewables and innovative
technologies that help us harness
our most prevalent and reliable energy
sources and
one of the things that i think is
exciting about some of the research
that's being done
is on carbon capture technology which
ought to be again
something that we all can all agree on
as we transition
to the next forms of energy
as we begin a new congress and welcome a
new president i'm once again reminded of
the words
that were quoted from ruth bader
ginsburg
recently deceased justice of the united
states supreme court
she didn't originate it but she did make
it popular when she said you can
disagree without being disagreeable
of course democracy itself is expects a
competition of ideas
but not necessarily the mudslinging and
name-calling that have become all too
common
i hope we can return to the respectful
battles
in the days and months ahead and know
that there's no better battleground for
that to happen in
the senate where sometimes sometimes
we live up to the billing as the world's
greatest deliberative body
feature that separates the senate from
the house
or any other legislative body is free
and full debate 60 votes to cut off
debates so you can then have a vote and
pass a piece of legislation
with 51 votes it forces us to do what we
ought to do
anyway which is to have fulsome debate
allow minority views to be presented and
then
once the debate is concluded then to
have a vote
on the underlying bill but fundamentally
the founders
saw the senate as a place that protected
minority
rights and i've been here long enough to
be in the majority
and in the minority and we know what
goes around
comes around in the united states senate
it's as sure as
day follows night and that's why we're
called a deliberative body
in the house you have 435 members and in
order to pass a bill
all you need is a majority got the votes
jam it through but there
has to be some place somewhere in a
nation of 330 million souls
where competing ideas can be seriously
debated
and that's why our founders created the
united states senate
george washington was famously said to
have told thomas jefferson that the
senate was
meant to be a saucer to cool
house legislation like a saucer was used
to cool
hot tea well if partisan bills are
the hot tea then the senate cloture
requirements are the saucer
rather than a simple majority here in
the senate you have to get 60 out of
100 senators to support a bill in order
for it to advance
i know we all would love to see each of
our ideas passed into law without any
delay
or extended debate but that's not the
way the senate
is supposed to work it forces us to do
what we ought to want to do anyway
which is to do the hard work of
bipartisan negotiation
and compromise come up with an 80 20
solution that can leave the 20 percent
you don't agree on
for another day in another battle but to
pass into law
and make progress on behalf of the
american people with the 80 percent we
can't agree on
well neither party has had a
filibuster-proof majority since the late
70s and as a result senators from red
states and blue states have had to work
together
as they should to reach agreements on
nearly every piece
of legislation that has moved through
this chamber in the last four decades
the only real exception is the records
budget reconciliation process which by
the
court the rules can be done with 51
votes but otherwise
in the main 60 votes a bipartisan
majority is required
in order to move legislation
when bills require bipartisan support in
order to pass
they're more durable the fact is if you
pass a
partisan piece of legislation the next
time the minority
majority flips they can undo it
well i think it's useful in terms of our
comedy in terms of our relationships in
terms of our
ability to get things done for the
american people to try to figure out how
to do things on a bipartisan basis
and while i know bipartisanship isn't
necessarily popular
with the political basis of either party
it's critical to our democracy
unfortunately some of our colleagues on
the other side have expressed an
interest in
using their newly gained powers in the
majority to blow up the filibuster
and to shatter that important cooling
saucer
make no mistake that would do
irreparable harm to this institution
and inflict serious damage on our
democracy
without the 60 vote cloture requirement
both chambers would be majority rule
institutions
with a steady flow of partisan
legislation moving through congress
if the same party controls both chambers
and the white house the party
that party could pass strictly partisan
legislation that would quickly be signed
into law without a single vote
from the opposing party does that feel
good
well if you're on the winning side yeah
is it good for the country
no it is not it's efficient
but it's not effective it's not lasting
it's not durable
it doesn't provide the sort of stability
and ability to plan
that the current structure provides
well all the reasons i've given for not
doing away with the senate cloture
requirement is the reason no majority
has ever
tried to blow it up before during the
past four administrations
the trump obama bush and clinton
administration there was a period of
time when the president's party
controlled both
chambers of congress if you go further
back in history you'll find dozens of
examples
but no senate until now
has ever been so short-sighted to get
rid of the cloture requirement in the
filibuster
when it comes to legislation
if democrats carried out their threat to
do that today they'd clear the path to
pass
a radical agenda that would
fundamentally reshape our country
without a single republican vote
as a reminder we have a 50-50 synod and
in the house there are 221 democrats and
211 republicans
in all of congress there are 10 more
democrats than republicans out of 535
members of congress that's far
from a progressive or a radical mandate
as i said elections happen majorities
change
presidents come and go as do united
states senators
in two years republicans could win the
majority in either
or both chambers and four a republican
could win the white house as well
if we were to do away with this
restraint on snap decisions and partisan
legislation
what would the succeeding republican
administration likely do
it would simply undo everything that had
been done on a partisan basis
well would our democratic colleagues
support a rule change to blow up the
filibuster when republicans control both
houses in the white house
would they believe the senate minority
should be silenced as they believe
now as i say what goes around comes
around
and the shoe is always on the other foot
eventually
the good news is we don't have to wonder
what the answer would be because we
already know it
in 2017 the republican-led senate house
and white house
when we held both houses and and the
white house there was fear by some folks
across the aisle actually both sides of
the aisle that the filibuster would be
limited in order to clear the path
for a republican agenda
that was when 61 senators a filler
buster-proof majority wrote a bipartisan
letter
to then majority leader mcconnell and
democratic leader schumer urging them to
protect
the filibuster of 61 senators
among the co-signers were 27 current
democratic
senators one of the signatures on this
bipartisan letter
is that of our newly sworn in vice
president kamala harris
i can promise you that leader mcconnell
has no interest in eliminating the
filibuster
when he was majority leader or now as
minority leader because he knew
the institutional damage that this would
cause in the damage to our
democracy unfortunately
leader schumer refuses to acknowledge
that most basic
fact the two party leaders are now in
the process of negotiating an organizing
resolution on how this new reality of a
50 50 senate will operate
fortunately there's a modern precedent
for how this has been
done and the two leaders have shared an
interest in emulating
the 2001 agreement negotiated by
tom daschle and trent lott
but because of the newfound obsession of
some on the left with
uprooting the cornerstone of the senate
leader mcconnell has asked for
assurances from
leader schumer that the filibuster and
the cloture requirement will remain
intact after all it's not unreasonable
to ask your negotiating partner
to commit to not breaking the rules
which is all
senator mcconnell is asking for senator
schumer
has derided that request calling it
extraneous
and saying it falls outside the bounds
of the 2001
organizing resolution but i'd like to
remind
our colleagues that in 2001 the majority
party was not threatening to blow up the
senate rules
to advance a partisan agenda that's why
it wasn't
the subject explicitly of that
negotiating
organizing resolution there's no need to
ask for assurances on the protection of
the filibuster because
it wasn't even a question to be answered
our democratic colleagues have relied on
the filibuster while republicans have
held
the majority i can think of time after
time after time we've had
tried to pass more coveted 19 relief
bills that our democratic colleagues
felt
was inadequate and time after time after
time they used
the filibuster to prevent passage of
that bill
which was their right i think a mistake
a decision i disagree with but within
their rights under the senate rules
republicans have also relied on the
filibuster while democrats
have held the majority we all recognize
that at some point the shoe is
always on the other foot
which is why no one has been so foolish
as to eliminate the legislative
filibuster
or even seriously to consider it before
i hope our colleagues on the other side
will avoid making
this tragic mistake in order to pursue
short-sighted political goals
and in an encouraging sign on friday the
white house and kate indicated that
president biden does not support
getting rid of the legislative
filibuster either
president biden has served in the senate
for i believe 36 years
he understands how this institution
works
how it's supposed to work and his advice
and its only advice since he's the
president and not a member of the senate
anymore
is don't go there
i encourage our more than two dozen
democratic colleagues who've repeatedly
voiced their support
for maintaining the legislative
filibuster to insist
that this critical stabilizing force in
our democracy be preserved
in the organizing resolution currently
being discussed by
senator schumer and senator mcconnell
i truly believe that if we don't
do that if the legislative filibuster
is eliminated that we will all rule
the day and president i yield the floor
and i know he'll be my colleague
the senator from tennessee thank you
madam president
i tell you i'm going to follow right
along with the
comments that my colleague from texas
has made because
in tennessee whether someone's a
republican
or a libertarian or an independent
or a democrat they have
very high expectations of what this
congress
is going to be able to accomplish
and they also have high expectations
for this administration um
what they are doing is looking there and
they're
saying politics and politicians
are not what this is all about they
don't necessarily
matter policies matter
and as my colleague is saying
maintaining the filibuster rule
in the senate allowing robust
respectful debate so that we arrive
at a sense of compromise
and we do what is best for
the american people and
today i was talking with one of our
tennesseans
and they were talking about it doesn't
matter what's being said on social media
on twitter or facebook or parlor
or any of the social media platforms
that when you strip it all away good
policy
is good people and that
is what matters good policy
is good policy it is good
for the people
and that is where the emphasis should be
so when i say they have expectations
i don't only mean
that they want good policies they want
this to
focus on them they want it to focus on
their concerns their
communities their schools
their right to feel secure
their right to enjoy
free speech their right
to pursue their happiness
their american dream their right
to celebrate and protect life
it's about them not politicians
not politics it's about the american
people
from their perspective we can spend
hours
debating the budget or immigration
reform or
data privacy which i'll talk more about
later this week
as long as at the end of the day
whatever compromise
we reach not only meets their needs but
recognizes that the people
are the most important part of this
entire
equation the people every member
of this body understands that when the
balance
of power shifts sometimes that means
that the guy across the aisle is going
to get the upper hand
things change but it would be a mistake
for my colleagues on the other side of
the aisle to assume
that that means we're willing to set our
priorities and our principles
aside
it doesn't mean that we're going to
submit to their agenda it doesn't mean
we are going to conform
to their agenda it means we're going to
stay
true to our principles
represent our
states and work
work diligently for what is going to be
best for the people we may have had a
changing of the guard
here in washington but it doesn't mean
that any of us
have set aside the promises that we have
made
to the people we represent and that's
why i came out
so strongly against the biden
administration
and the president's executive order that
really
crushed the jobs and the potential for
energy security that came with the
building
of the keystone xl pipeline
this was a project that had achieved
bipartisan
support and what are we seeing now lost
jobs
lost livelihoods more money being taken
out of the taxpayer's pocket for similar
reasons
i came out in opposition to rejoining
the paris climate accords
and reversing our course
on the departure from the world health
organization
for me this isn't about politics it's
about the policies
this new administration has decided to
unilaterally say yes to
without consulting congress
without including the people
in the discussion and just so we're all
aware
president biden said yes to
more unilateral policy changes on
day one than any
president in our nation's history
more than any president in our nation's
history
the biden administration looked at those
new policies
and decided that the result achieving
that outcome
was worth whatever it would cost
the american people to get it
so over the next few weeks we'll also
be examining the president's cabinet
picks
to get a sense of the trade-off they'll
be willing to make safety is at the
forefront of
everyone's mind back home in tennessee
not just safety from covet but from the
bad actors and the foreign adversaries
who continue to show
us just how far they're willing to go to
undermine us
on the world stage back in tennessee
we have a saying when somebody shows you
who
they really are you better believe them
and i will tell you that they are paying
attention and i will tell you
that they are not very impressed right
now with some of the so-called
self-talk that they're hearing on
proposed policies
toward iran and the communist regime
in china this is why i chose
not to support the confirmation of our
new director of national intelligence
avril haynes i also had some pretty
tough questions to ask
secretary of state nominee blinken
about some of these same issues dealing
with iran
dealing with china and many of the
proposals
that i'm hearing from them have sounded
strangely
familiar from years gone by
we don't have to look overseas to find
some very real policy differences
between what tennesseans have said they
expect
and what the biden administration is
signaling that they want to deliver
in his hearing before the commerce
committee
transportation secretary nominee pete
buda judge signaled to the panel
that he would put the administration's
environmental goals
ahead of some very basic changes to
federal policy
that would lighten the regulatory load
on county and city mayors trying to get
their transportation projects
off the ground as i told him many times
the regulations at issue
don't just slow the projects down they
kill the project
and that town's prospects for growth
for a better life for people in the
community
hopefully he's going to keep in mind
what it means to these
mayors the next time he's asked to
consider the benefits
of removing unnecessary
red tape these trade-offs many times
are just too destructive to say yes to
and i would encourage
all of my colleagues to look at the
compromises the president
is asking each and every one to make
not just in terms of what we stand to
gain
but what is going to be the cost what is
the monetary cost
what is the cost of freedom what is the
opportunity
cost that will be delivered
to the american people in order
for the administration to have their
way to get their income
that is the question we should each ask
what is the cost to the american people
in order to protect them in order to
meet the expectations
that they have and we should be
listening to the people
this policies are about them
i yield the floor
madam president senator from oregon
madam president i have one request
for committees to meet during today's
session of the senate
they have the approval of the majority
and minority leaders
duly noted
madam president it is a pleasure tonight
to be making the case for janet yellen
former chair of the federal reserve to
be the next
secretary of treasury it is
an awfully easy case to make
chair janet yellen deserves to be
in the senate confirmation hall of fame
she has already been confirmed four
times
for key economic positions
tonight the senate can deliver an
especially
important economic judgment
confirm janet yellen a fifth time
and know that she will work with
every single one of us to get
our workers our small businesses
and all americans from sea
to shining sea back on solid
economic footing tonight i'm going to
spend just a few minutes
discussing several important matters
we learned from chair yellen's
confirmation hearing
first chair yellen is an exceptional
economist who has a rare
gift she can take complicated
economic theories and put them into
understandable language all
while showing a real heart for the
millions of americans who are
hurting through no fault of their
own i asked chair yellen at her
confirmation hearing
what will give americans
the most bang for the economic
recovery buck and chair yellen
simply walked through the priorities
particularly going to bat
for our small businesses i come from a
state
where we have only a handful of big
businesses
we're overwhelmingly a small business
state
and then her confirmation hearing she
spoke clearly
about those small business needs and she
talked about
the concerns she has for innovative
and important approaches to expanding
unemployment expanding unemployment
benefits excuse me
to make sure that we're meeting the
needs
of our people and she also focused
on reducing hunger and approaches
that will help stretch anti-hunger
dollars
second chair yellen knows that it would
be a big
mistake for the congress to go small
on economic relief she's acutely aware
of what happened in 2009
when the government took its foot
off the economic gas pedal too
soon and recovery was compromised as a
result
and she also understands that emergency
economic relief like unemployment
compensation
needs to last as long as the
emergency it cannot be tied
to arbitrary expiration dates where
potential agendas come
or potential political agendas come
before
human needs there's a reason
why the finance committee approved her
nomination unanimously
on friday morning and i touched on
some of those factors and i'm going to
amplify
a little bit for example nobody deserves
more credit than chair yellen for the
longest economic expansion
in american history it lasted until the
pandemic hit
as federal reserve chairs she led an
important change
to the status quo in economic policy
previously there had been too great a
focus
on inflation and deficits chair yellen
said
let's zero in more on unemployment
income and inequality and she believed
that the
economy could run a bit hotter
the record shows that the yellen
approach
was right on unemployment went down
wages went up
and a lot of people were better off than
they were before
that's exactly the kind of thinking
america needs again because confronting
the coveted economy is hammering working
families in particular
again another clear reason why janet
yellen is the right pick
to be the next treasury secretary the
most recent
economic data shows that 1.4 million
people nationwide had filed new claims
for unemployment benefits in the last
full week of the previous administration
so it's not hard to figure out what that
means
it's an economic catastrophe
it's more than twice the highest figure
from any single week in the great
recession
that means 1.4 million people so so
many working families are suddenly
walking on an economic tightrope every
single
day balancing the food costs against the
fuel costs
fuel costs against the rent bill
worried about finding a new job
getting a badly needed shift at work
falling behind on rent or the mortgage
feeding their kids paying the electric
bills
paying medical bills worried that
the recovery is headed in reverse
and worried about whether the congress
will be gridlocked the country lost 140
000 jobs last month
my home state lost more than 25 000
in part because the senate
in something that just defied common
sense
waited around for the recovery to peter
out
before passing any more relief
thousands and thousands of neighborhood
restaurants and bars and mom-and-pop
businesses
have been shuttered nearly 11 million
workers
are out of the job another four million
americans have fallen
out of the labor force entirely
since this time last year unless the
congress
acts boldly and quickly with more relief
the damage from the covet economic crash
will long outlast the pandemic
itself that must not be allowed
to happen
the key of course is for the senate to
get down to work
and one of the best ways you can do it
is to confirm someone who is
eminently qualified chair janet yellen
to be treasury secretary
as i touched on we're looking at working
with her
on a coast on a host of key economic
issues as i've said as the
new chair of the finance committee my
first priority
will make sure that this congress
does not commit again
the mistake of 2009. in 2009
the sense was well maybe we're getting
there on economic recovery
we'll be able to come back later
if maybe we didn't do enough
well we all know that a missed
opportunity
is a missed opportunity and
in 2009 the congress said
all right we can take our foot off the
gas now
it was too early and there wasn't any
next effort to make up for the damage
i'm committed
to making sure that doesn't happen uh
again
and suffice it to say in 2009 it took
seven and a half years for the
unemployment rate in oregon
to return to its pre-recession levels
this time
around the congress has been warned
the warning i'm giving about making sure
the congress doesn't take its foot off
the
economic relief a pedal too soon
it's not the first warning chair powell
for example made it clear that the
biggest danger
lies in not doing enough increasing
relief checks to two thousand dollars is
key
the congress needs to increase and
extend
unemployment benefits for the entirety
of the covid crisis and you
do that by in effect
tying the benefits to the real world
to economic conditions on the ground
and that's been my proposal for some
time
other colleagues have long advanced
similar
ideas it is not a revolutionary
proposition to say emergency
relief should last as long as the
emergency
simply stated and not
be held up not be held hostage
by the arbitrary political agendas
of members of congress if you don't do
it dysfunction and gridlock in congress
creates still more havoc for people
who've done nothing wrong and just need
help
a decade ago that help went away too
quickly
because benefits expired arbitrarily and
congress
did not keep up with extensions the
congress
needs to do better i believe
that should include important upgrades
as well to unemployment insurance which
was created
in the last century i don't think it's
too much to say we
at least bring a critical safety net
program
into the relevant century
now sometimes these programs look a
little
uh rusty in the modern economy sometimes
it's because of outright outright
sabotage
but workers suffer particularly
black and hispanic workers and so there
are steps that need to be taken in
addition to modernizing the benefits
increasing base benefits bringing all
workers into the system
and ensuring it can hold up in a crisis
finally chair yellen had some important
comments on fixing
america's broken tax code
and i will tell you madam president i
start with the proposition
that a nurse who's treating
covid patients and paying taxes
with every single paycheck
should not face themselves
in a disadvantaged position when
compared to billionaires
who in effect do no such thing and
can postpone and postpone and postpone
paying their taxes now there's a lot of
work we need to do
to repair the 2017 bill the previous
administration
actually increased the incentive for
corporations to fix
job to ship jobs overseas i want to fix
that mistake
i want to work with secretary yellen on
energy policy
because so much of it deals with the tax
code
and suffice it to say those are just
some of the challenges that chair yellen
will face
when i believe she is confirmed tonight
as treasury secretary supremely
qualified a member
in my view of the senate confirmation
hall of fame a
proven economic policy maker
and finally i say to my colleagues
on both sides of the aisle it is long
past time to have a woman
lead the u.s treasury department chair
yellen's got my
full support as colleagues come for this
vote and it's a significant economic
policy
vote make no mistake about that
i just asked colleagues to reflect on
the fact
that chair yellen was approved by the
finance committee
26 to nothing
sometimes i say about this place i have
questions whether you can get a simple
decision
like ordering a sandwich decided on a 26
to nothing she was approved unanimously
because she gives public service
a good name i urge my colleagues
to support janet yellen for secretary
of treasury when we vote in just a few
minutes madam chair i yield the floor
senator from kansas madam president
thank you
um
i want to visit this evening on the
senate floor and
take this opportunity to recognize a
public servant a leader
our former secretary of the army the
honorable ryan
d mccarthy secretary mccarthy
led our nation's army from september 30
2019 to january
20 2021 and during that time he made
it a more modern agile and lethal
fighting force
we have worked together on a number of
projects for kansans
and those who serve or have served on
our nation
during this his tenure as secretary
acting secretary and under secretary of
the army
and i've grown to consider him a good
solid
friend one of my most memorable
experiences
in the senate is visiting the first
infantry division soldiers in germany
and poland
soldiers that come from fort riley
kansas
uh with the secretary followed by our
trip to afghanistan to meet with troops
on the front lines in the global war on
terror
those visits mark the beginning of our
friendship and since then i've
appreciated his guidance and his support
during his visits to kansas and our many
discussions here in the nation's capital
in 2019 secretary mccarthy joined me in
kansas to
visit sites elementary school which
serves as families of the big red one
soldiers and their on fort riley
secretary mccarthy was instrumental in
helping to find
funding for this school in 2011 when he
was the special assistant defense
secretary
robert gates a kansan
i was pleased he joined me in kansas to
visit the school and students
that he helped create in 2019 we also
met with fort riley leadership
and then traveled to wichita to visit
defense manufacturing and academic
leaders to discuss the future
of army procurement these personal touch
points with soldiers and with the army
community were some of the reasons why
secretary mccarthy was universally
respected
within the army family while i will
always appreciate our personal
engagements with soldiers
i will also remember our efforts to
support soldiers and veterans
when they step off the battlefield or
separate from military service
this past veterans day we co-authored an
editorial that discussed our parallel
efforts to support the mental health and
well-being
of soldiers and veterans reports show
americans across the country are feeling
isolated
and alone in today's socially distanced
environment including our nation's
servicemen
and women and veteran populations
between my efforts as chairman of the
senate veterans affairs committee to
implement the commander
john scott hannon veterans mental health
improvement act
and secretary mccarthy's effort to build
interpersonal connections
between soldiers we are working to give
soldiers and veterans
the tools they need to overcome mental
health challenges they face
as secretary mccarthy transitions out of
the watchful eye of
public life i rise this evening to
express my appreciation for his
leadership
his character and his moral compass he
never let politics or convenience
influence his decisions
and that has significantly benefited
soldiers army civilians and veterans in
kansas and across the nation
as the chairman and now ranking member
of the senate veterans affairs committee
i will always strive to help veterans
find
success after service secretary mccarthy
i have no doubt that you will find
success
and happiness after your dedicated
service to our country
i wish you and your family and i thank
your family for their support of your
public service
but i know that you and your family will
find
a quality life with purpose and meaning
as you enter the next phase
madam president i yield the floor
madam president senator from louisiana i
ask unanimous consent to complete my
remarks before the scheduled roll call
vote
without objection
madam president i rise today to
recognize and thank
three long-serving aides who have served
my office but more importantly served
our nation proudly
and they are now moving on to the next
chapters of their life
first chris gillot chris chilot was my
legislative director
and for eight years has been my right
hand personal policy
he never failed to take the ideas we
discussed together
and craft the actual policy needed to
make a meaningful difference
in the lives of folks in louisiana and
the lives of all americans
he was a master at navigating the
partisan divide
to find areas of convict of consensus
upon which we could build to advance
real solutions
and as always truck he's on the first
name basis with the legislative director
of
and fill in the democratic senator or
the republican senator's name
he had a sense that in the in the era
before zoom calls they would go out and
have a beer on a regular basis
and that helped us tremendously
we saw this fully on display recently
as chris was a central figure in the
so-called 908
coalition which jumped started stalled
coveted relief packages
and it wasn't just the relationships
between the senators
but again as i spoke between the
different legislative directors
from both parties all offices his
efforts were also have been central to
passing legislation to ban surprise
medical
billing a more than two-year effort
that will have a direct and positive
impact
on the pocketbooks of american families
he was crucial in our effort to make
health care more affordable
pass generational tax reform for every
major legislative pursuit
i could rely upon chris but many in
louisiana may not know that he's also
been a central
central figure engaged in some of the
most pressing issues affecting our state
including offshore energy production
revenue sharing
energy regulation permitting the
national flood insurance program
and public works related to flood
protection
all important to the well-being of our
state the folks who lived there
as well as our entire country and all
these were regularly under assault
chris was a fearless advocate for energy
production
and for the jobs that energy production
creates to not only help meet america's
energy needs
but to meet the individual family's
financial needs he has been on the front
lines to prevent changes to revenue
sharing
that would gut the money used in my
state for hurricane protection
flood mitigation and coastal
environmental renewal
he has defended the national flood
insurance program
to ensure that this critical lifeline
remains accessible to people
across the country and important to
those in louisiana
thank you chris for all that you've done
for me and for those of louisiana
the next person i will speak of
is allison kapzner sally allison is a
minnesotan
she said she grew up on the upper end of
the mississippi but she found a home
in the lower end of the mississippi or
at least the office that represented
louisiana
she joined my staff at the beginning of
my first senate term
as a scheduler but through sheer
excellence
became deputy chief of staff and a close
confidante
trust is so important i learned i could
always trust ali's judgment
and her ability to accomplish anything
she is irreplaceable
she's had an impact on this office
ensuring that we better serve louisiana
but that impact has meant that we will
better serve louisiana even after her
departure
examples for any office to succeed it
needs to run efficiently
and effectively i knew this that we had
to have systems
ali figured out the systems she
implemented them across
all the offices here in d.c and
louisiana she kept
things running smoothly and she has a
skill of identifying an
individual strength and helping that
individual leverage those strengths
into results that contributed to the
whole but also to the future of the
individual
i'm about to say this about ali but i
can say it of chris and also of david
whom i'm about to speak of
uh mark chapter 10 verses 42 through
42 42-45 jesus speaks about
servant leadership and there is the
quote the greatest among you shall be
your servants
ali is someone who served others and
helped others serve as well
whether it be our staff our mission our
constituents the state of louisiana or
the united states of america
she served creatively and tirelessly she
will be greatly missed
but i am looking forward to all that she
achieves as she enters
the next phase of her career now let me
speak of david mills
a louisiana native a man of tremendous
character and deep
faith who served for five years on
my staff he came to washington because
he felt
called to give back to a state nation
through public office through public
through public service he was working in
congress for the right reasons
and his work reflected that david
handled pro-life
issues and other legal issues for my
office
he was key in last year's impeachment
trial
as an attorney providing quick reliable
research
to supplement my understanding of the
testimony that we heard
david also has the ability just to note
something others don't notice
and then very gently suggest some
modification
of how i would handle a situation and
that modification
although nuanced could be so important
and i really learned to
to trust those insights david also
handled privacy issues
and he's laid the foundation for work
that will continue
after he has left us as society becomes
more technologically centered
we must ensure the data privacy laws
keep up
david was on the forefront of that
thinking how do we protect the privacy
of consumers
as i mentioned this will be an important
issue in this upcoming congress
and just let me be specific david
developed legislation on questions
regarding the data
that is collected from a wearable a
smart watch
a contact tracing app and other info
other information that provides
personal health information but which is
not covered by current
personal health information laws
our office will continue to build on
david's work in those areas
and i thank david for all that he has
done sometimes madam president people
say oh my gosh
those folks who are younger than those
of us in the senate
is there something lacking i can promise
you among these there is nothing lacking
they are the leaders that will take your
place in my place
as we pass the baton to the next
generation and turn they shall pass to
another
to leave our future brighter than it has
been in the past
and with that madam president i yield
is there a sufficient second there
appears to be
question is on the nomination the yeas
and nays are ordered
clerk will call the roll miss baldwin mr
barrasso
mr bennett mrs blackburn mr blumenthal
mr blunt mr booker mr bozeman
mr braun mr brown mr burr
ms cantwell
this is capital
mr garden
mr carver
mr casey
mr cassidy
mr cassidy miss collins
mr coons
mr cornyn
miss cortez masto
uh
mr kramer
mr crapo mr cruz
mr danes miss duckworth
mr durbin ms ernst
mrs feinstein mrs fisher
mrs gillibram mr
graham mr grassley
mr hagerty miss hassan
mr hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
miss serrano
mr hoeven
mr johnson mr kane
mr kelly
mr kennedy mr king
miss klobuchar mr lankford
mr leahy
mr lee
mr lujan
miss llamas
mr mansion
mr mansion mr markey
mr marshall mr mcconnell
mr menendez mr merkley
mr moran miss markowski
mr murphy
mrs murray
mr ossoff
mr padilla mr paul
mr peters mr portman
mr reed
mr risch
mr romney
it's rosen
mr rounds mr rubio
mr sanders
mr stass
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby miss cinema
ms smith
ms stabenow
mr sullivan
mr tester
mr thune
mr tillis mr toomey
mr tuberville
mr van hollen
mr warner
mr warnock
miss warren
mr whitehouse mr wicker
mr wyden
mr young
senators voting in the affirmative
cantwell cardin cassidy
crapo duckworth feinstein
hyde smith inhofe johnson
kane kelly leahy menendez
merkley moran padilla peters
rosen shots white house
widen senators voting in the negative
cotton hawley
mr mansion mr mansion
i mr marshall mr marshall
i
mrs gillibrand mrs gillibrand i
mrs shaheen mrs shaheen
i
miss llamas miss lummus i
kennedy mr kennedy i
mr brown mr brown i
so
the cinema miss cinema i
mr bennett mr bennett i
mrs murray mrs murray aye
mr romney mr romney aye
miss stabenow miss kavanaugh i
you
mr bozeman mr bozeman no
this
mr tester mr tester i
mr carver mr carver i
miss collins miss collins i
mr booker mr booker
aye mr warner mr warner
i miss hassan miss hassan
i mr blumenthal mr blumenthal
i
mr paul mr paul
[Music]
no
drosoph mr ossoff i
mr rounds mr rounds uh
mr graham mr graham i
you
mr rono mr rono i
mr sanders mr sanders i
mr reed mr reed
is
young mr young aye
mr hove and mr hoeven no mr burr mr burr
i
so
mr durbin mr durbin i
mr van hollen mr van hollen i
mr langford mr lankford i
miss cortez masto miss cortez masto
i
mr lujan mr luhan aye ms murkowski mr
murkowski
aye
mr tubberville mr tubberville
no
you
casey mr casey
i
mr toomey mr toomey aye
mr murphy mr murphy i
mr sass mr sasse
so
mr king mr king
i
mr scott mr scott of south carolina i
mr danes mr danes aye
mr rish mr risch
no mr shelby mr shelby
no
mrs blackburn mrs blackburn no
you
mr cornyn mr cornyn i mr warnock
mr warnock i mr markey mr markey
i miss smith miss smith
i
mean mr heinrich i
mr blunt mr blount aye
mr waker mr wicker
aye
hey mr grassley i
mr hickenlooper mr hickenlooper aye
miss baldwin miss baldwin aye mrs capito
mrs capito
aye
mr rosso mr barrasso no
mr lee mr
i
mrs fisher mrs fisher
aye mr coons mr coons i
so
mr kramer mr kramer
no
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell aye
miss klobuchar miss klobuchar
i
mr tillis mr tillis is
mr portman mr portman i
mr scott mr scott of florida
no
you
mr schumer mr schumer aye
mr aggerty mr hagerty aye
mr dune mr dunes i
mr cruz mr cruz
no
mr braun mr brawn aye
miss ernst i
you
you
you
mr sullivan mr sullivan no
does any senator wish to vote or change
their vote if not the a's
are 84. the nays are 15
and the confirmation is confirmed the
nomination is confirmed
under the previous order the motion to
reconsider is considered made
and laid upon the table and the
president will be immediately notified
of the senate's action madam president
senior senator from minnesota madam
president i ask unanimous consent that
the senate proceed to legislative
session and be in a period of morning
business
with senators permitted to speak therein
for up to
10 minutes each without objection
madam president junior senator from
alaska
madam president i want to be one of the
first senators to congratulate dr yellen
now secretary
yellen to be secretary of the treasury
of the united states uh you saw as a
strong vote
and um there's no doubt that she has the
credentials the experience the
qualifications
uh to be secretary of the treasury
former chairman of the fed
i mean her resume is off the charts and
i know
her nomination is historic for so many
women across the country including my
three daughters
so madam president i'm mentioning this
because i certainly intended
to vote for now secretary yellen and
i was a no vote and i want to explain my
novel
because i had a very good conversation
with her
just the other day we covered a whole
bunch of topics
everything from alaska native
corporations to the strength of the
dollar
to
our debt and deficit big macro economic
in the country
particularly as we're in a recession
important to my state
but we got to the topic of energy
we got to the topic of energy and
reluctantly i am saying this now because
i was a bit
shocked that despite a
long robust discussion um
it was very difficult to get her
from my perspective to commit
to being a secretary of the treasury
the most important economic player in
any cabinet
in any government in the u s government
besides of course the president
to commit to being a strong advocate for
a robust
all-of-the-above energy sector for the
u.s economy
now madam president this is not a
radical proposition
i would argue that every secretary of
the treasury since alexander hamilton
has been a robust supporter of resource
development
in our energy sector again all of it
renewables oil gas
and the reason is is because it's been
such an important driver of economic
growth
and jobs
for pretty much our entire nation's
existence
and now that we're in this recession
deep recession and we need job growth
good job grows
and we need a strong recovery
to me having the sector of the treasury
be a strong proponent
in the debates about policy for the
energy sector
i thought was a no-brainer as a matter
of fact i think
pretty much every sector of the treasury
has been that person
and again the 2008-2009 recession the
deep great recession
the number one driver of economic growth
and job growth and capital formation for
the u.s economy was
the energy sector and it was supported
democrats and republicans for decades
have supported a strong
energy sector but despite a long
respectful debate with now secretary
yellen who i certainly won't have a good
relationship with
could not get that commitment which i
thought was surprising
as a matter of fact i thought it was
shocking and it's the reason
i reluctantly voted no because again she
is
very qualified
madam president what's going on here is
we're we're starting to see
policies
that i believe need a national debate
a national debate we're starting to see
policies
yes we all want renewables clean energy
but we have a really important strong
energy sector
prior to the pandemic we were the
world's
superpower of energy again one of the
reasons we won world war
ii is because of our energy sector
and the men and women who have been
producing energy
all of the above energy are great
patriotic workers who've been doing it
for decades
to the benefit of every single american
but we need a debate because what i'm
starting to see
with the new administration
unfortunately and i've had discussions
and hopefully they're not going to go
down this path
is executive actions that are going to
target
certain sectors of the energy sector the
us economy
natural gas we can be
dominant natural gas for 100 years
we're going to start targeting workers
in the natural gas sector
oil i know some people don't like oil
but it's important
we can do all of this but right now
there seems to be
hostility towards the sector
and the workers in no debate
we should have that debate it's an
important debate
it's really important to my state but i
think it's really important to america
every segment secretary of the treasury
for the last
three four five six seven decades since
world war ii has always sought
the goal of getting america back to
energy independence
that's good for jobs it's good for
low-cost manufacturing it's good to
reduce the heating and energy bills
of american families it's good for our
national security it's good for our
foreign policy
and we are pretty much on the verge of
doing this
and now we're going to start to
unilaterally disarm
we've gotten to the point where i can't
find anyone
and i hope i'm wrong in the bind
administration cabinet who's going to be
a proponent
of a strong energy sector who is it
i was hoping it was going to be the
sector of the treasury maybe
maybe an hour long discussion i
misinterpreted
where she's going to be on this issue
but pretty much every previous secretary
democrat republican
in the history of our great nation has
really
really been an advocate for the men and
women who work in this sector
and for the economic growth it brings
for the help it brings to families and
the good jobs it brings
so madam president that's the rationale
behind my boat
you know right now i think we're
starting to see whether it's the
keystone pipeline decision
the men and women in the building trades
who have built this country
through hard work they're being laid off
by the thousands we've had a big scare
back home in my state
all weekend i was working this issue of
these executive orders from the biden
administration
where it looked like it was going to
send hundreds of people home unemployed
oil and gas workers in my state
why i hope that's not the case
especially during a recession but we
need a debate on it
and i certainly hope somebody in this
administration
when their principals meetings talk
about how we get good jobs
strong working class i've noticed the
national security advisor jake sullivan
keeps talking about
we're going to base our policies on
working class families you can't get
more
blue collar strong middle class than
these energy sector jobs
so i certainly want to have a good
constructive relationship with the
secretary of the treasury and her team
but given the people i represent and
what i'm starting to see right now i
could not in good conscience
vote yes
when the basic question of are you
committed will be a strong advocate for
a strong energy sector
all of the above you name it renewables
natural gas wind solar
all the above and because i couldn't get
that commitment
i reluctantly voted no
on someone who's got a background and
experience
in these other areas that's important
for the country i yield the floor adam
president
senator from rhode island and a
president i have
hastened to the floor because i was
upstairs waiting for the house managers
to
bring the articles over and i heard my
friend
the distinguished senator from alaska
talking about
his concern about the fossil fuel part
of the energy
sector and his um dissatisfaction with
what
the secretary of the treasury was able
to assure him in that regard
and i just wanted to note that i missed
a moment of
the senator's remarks when i came
walking down here
but as best i could tell the senator
never mentioned the term climate change
never referenced carbon emissions
and i have to say if we're going to deal
with our energy sector
we have to deal with it in a way that
takes into account
carbon emissions and climate change you
can't just
whistle past those things madam
president and pretend that they're not
real
and act as if we can continue to go
forward the way we always have
releasing carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere poisoning our oceans with
acidification
warming the planet putting coastal
communities like mine at
grave risk from sea level rise and storm
surge
we have to address those things
and as we go forward in this new
congress i very much hope that my friend
senator sullivan and i will be able to
work together
to address that exact problem to make
sure
that not only is our energy mix strong
for our economy
but to make absolutely sure that we are
not sacrificing the safety of our planet
the economic security of our
future generations the health
of people all around the planet who have
really no choice but to live close to
the land
and feel the pounding of climate change
in their immediate lives every day
we have to address those things and i
hope we will
so having heard his side of the argument
i just wanted to come back to the floor
and offer the other side and somewhere
between us
there is a resolution because i know
perfectly well that the state of alaska
is getting hit by the acidification and
warming side by the sea level rise and
storm
surge side of this problem
just as much as rhode island is and
perhaps because as my friend constantly
reminds me
uh alaska has a huge advantage
of size over rhode island one could even
imagine that they are having more of an
effect than rhode island so with those
comments and with affection and regard
for
my colleague from alaska i yield the
floor
the senator from alaska as a lot of our
colleagues here know
senator whitehouse is not just a
distinguished senator but one of my very
good friends here in the u.s senate so i
always respect
what he has to say and i appreciate his
words and he and i have done a lot of
work
some key work particularly on issues of
the environment
cleaning up our oceans ocean
acidification and i look forward to
continuing to to work with him my point
is
that and climate change is certainly
happening in my state we're seeing it
no doubt about it my point is
um when you have a
economy that's in recession and you have
tens of thousands literally hundreds of
thousands of people out of work
and you have a sector that's important
critical actually the energy sector no
doubt about it
i know we can use words like spewing and
polluters
the energy sector has been one of the
things that has made
this country so strong with great jobs
and middle class jobs and people can't
deny that
and all i'm asking for is the new
secretary of the treasury
has to look at that when we're looking
at the whole us
economy and the strength of our recovery
and good paying jobs
that has to be taken into account and
what i worry is
that it's not and we need a debate and i
would welcome it with my good friend
on what is the strategy but the strategy
out of the box can't be
we're going to go after these oil and
gas jobs
and put people out of work and replace
it with what we had a hearing in the
commerce committee
with the new transportation secretary
incoming transportation sector
a lot of people ask well what are you
going to replace it with
what are you telling the 10 000 guys who
just lost their job on the keystone
pipeline what their new job is going to
be they have mortgages
they have tuition to pay they're out of
work
right now so we need a strategy i'm not
in look i look forward to working with
all these
issues with my good friend from rhode
island
but it is i think of first
if you look back at the great history of
this nation
if you don't have a u.s treasury sector
secretary or
other members of the cabinet who are for
a robust strong energy sector
which of course would include renewables
that's new
that's different and i think it's very
troubling particularly as it relates
to the jobs that i think are going to be
sacrificed
on a policy and a strategy that i have
not seen the meat and bones of yet
i'm just seeing the damage and a lot of
the damage
is starting to happen to people i care
about particularly
in my state who work in these sectors
and are great americans who have about
helped build this country built my state
and we can't just disregard them
and say don't worry you're going to get
a green job later
it's tough to tell people that it's
tough to tell people that
when they got a mortgage and tuition
and we're relying on that so i commit to
continue to work with these issues and
others with my friend from what island i
appreciate him coming down here
but i want to explain my vote on an
issue that i think we need to debate
here in the senate that's important
for our nation i yield the floor
the senator from rhode island i would
just close by um
suggesting that perhaps my friend the
senator from alaska can
sympathize since he fears that the
interests that he came to the floor here
to defend will not be listened to
perhaps he can sympathize with the fact
that for four years
an entire administration wouldn't give
the time of day
to the sea level rise concerns that are
threatening my state
we are talking about freddie mac talking
about a property value crash
across all of our coasts
it's going to cause enormous harm to
rhode island
and we just left an administration that
wouldn't pay
one iota of attention to that they had
fossil fuel industry climate deniers and
there is such a thing not everybody in
the fossil fuel industry is that way
but they pick the bottom feeders to
bring into government
so i share the senator's frustration
but let me say i've got it about 10 000
times over
after having lived with the trump
administration for the past four years
and gotten
nothing having tried to bring serious
climate debate to the floor and knowing
that the republican leader was going to
block it so yeah
i i sympathize with his distress
and i hope he sympathizes with my rather
greater
cumulative distress from the last four
years i yield the floor
the clerk will call the rule ms baldwin
you